يصير سريعا تعرض لاطلاق النار وهذا ما حدث
ايضا الصوره ستخبر وتؤكد عن
نزوح بعض المواطنين من المناطق المتاخمه
لقاعده مروي العسكريه الى داخل هذه
المدينه الان هنالك بعض المواطنين
يحاولون ان يلوذوا بالفرار كما تتابعون
الحصرية المصاحبه بصوت اطلاق يذهبون خالد
الى داخل المدينه لاهلهم نعم لاهلهم الى
ذويهم يحاولون ان يحتموا بكل ما من شانه
ان يوفر الامن والسلام والاستقرار خالد
ساحاول ايضا ان انقل صوره معبره يعني انا
الان اتحدث ومن خلفي هذه الصوره وهذا
المشهد للمواطنين الذين يتابعون النقل
المباشر لقناه العربيه ويتابعون الاخبار
اول باول وهم ينظرون بعين الترقب وبعين
اللهفه وبعينا الطمانينه هل ستمضي الامور
الى مزيد من الانفجار هل ستهدا الامور هم
يلاحظون الان كما نلاحظ
ونشاهد مشاهد العربيه اعمده الدخان التي
تنتشر والاستماع الى صوت المدفعيه الثقيله
كما نسمع الان
تستمع خالد طيب هل تريد هل تريد ان تاخذ
ارائهم نزار نستمع الي ماذا يقولون الان
نعم نستمع خالد الى ارائهم هم الان من
يكتون بنيران هذه القضيه
لديهم راي واضح حول ما حدث نستمع الى بعض
الاعراض الحاجه اللي حصلت دي رايكم فيها
شنو باختصار وبوضوح والله حاجه جديده
علينا طبعا حاجه جديده في البلد دي
فالنادي المفروض يخلوا عندهم دينه ايمان
احنا نسواننا في الشوارع اطفالنا في
الشوارع زي ما شايف انت وراك ذيل الاطفال
قبل شوي انا في البيت جابوا لي مضروبات
برصاص خيطتهم في البيت يعني شغل ذاته ما
مفهومه وما معروفه جايه من وين ذاته شكرا
جزيلا اصوات مطالبه بتحكيم صوت العقل
باهميه ان ينقى المواطن عن كل هذه
الصراعات التي تحدث الان
الموضوع ده جديد علينا
والموضوع روح على المواطنين جدا يعني هسه
قبل في السوق كانت الاحداث مبالغ فيها
يعني حتى الناس جارين والموضوع زي ده جديد
علينا حتى الناس ما نبهوا يعني انت الان
في اطلاق نار في اشتباكات داخل القاعده
بالطالب شنو كمواطنين منطقه مروه لو سمحت
والله نحن بنطالب بانه يعني الاحداث دي
تتلاشى ونحاول الدعم السريع دمج مع القوات
المسلحه
والاشكالات تتحلل والاتفاق الايطالي يواصل
في في برنامج الحاصل فيه
خالد كانت هذه بعض الاصوات قبل ان اختتم
سنحاول ايضا ان نعيد التفكير بهذا المشهد
الذي تتابعه انت وكل مشاهدي العرب هل هناك
معلومات تواصل وتمدد اعمده عن سقوط اصابات
او قتلى جراء هذا القصف من صفوف قوه الدعم
السريعه من الجيش لا معلومات لارقام عن
ذلك
طبعا طبعا خالد فيما يتعلق بعدد المصابين
او الضحايا هذا الامر
بطبيعه الوضع العسكري والامني متروك
للبيانات الرسميه نحن لا نستطيع ان نتكهن
واضح او نعطي تقدير ولكن المؤكد بانما
رايناه وتابعناه وشاهدناه ونقلناه حصريا
بان
حجم
الدمار الذي شاهدناه عبر اعمده الدخان هذا
يشير الى ان هنالك خسائر ربما كبيره في
المركبات وفي العتاد وربما ايضا ضحايا
واصابات في صفوف القوات المسلحه او من قبل
الدعم السريع لان هذه الاشتباكات متواصله
منذ اكثر من ساعتين او ثلاثه وما زلنا
نستمع الى اصوات النار ونستمع ايضا الى
اصوات المواطنين الذين يرفعون الصوت بانه
هنالك شعب واحد وجيش واحد ولا بد من حسم
ما يسمونها بالفوضى التي وصلت اليها
مدينتهم مدينه مروي لمتابعه المزيد
من الاخنج
والقز اشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب
الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس
التنبيهات